hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well one
important type
or sense of justice which aristotle
discusses
in nick mccain ethics book five and also
mentions
in a few other works like the politics
and in particular the rhetoric
is what we could call legal justice
and what we're talking about there is
justice that is in some way
bound up with legality with an existing
framework of laws the greek word is
nomos which can mean
law can also mean custom and the general
idea is that
every single society whether these are
written
or unwritten has some set of
norms some structures that are
distinctive
to that society and which regulate
the understanding of what's right and
what's wrong the expectations about
behavior now
there's a few things that come up in the
nico mccann ethics discussion there's
some other things that come up in the
rhetoric discussion but i don't want to
go into those uh in part because i want
to just focus in these core concept
videos on one
text so
if we understand justice
in a certain sense as lawfulness
or legality then another way in which we
can understand it when it comes to
individuals
is being law abiding being
nomi nominos or nomicos following the
law
on that sort of conception is what is
just
so if i for example
um want to pay my taxes
by april 15th then
and i do that then i'm following the law
i am just in that sense that doesn't
mean that i'm a just person
overall or in any any greater sense in
order for me to be
to be a just person overall i in this
sense of
law abiding this i would have to
actually be following
all or at least most at least the ones
i'm capable of doing the laws that are
applicable to me
over time as a pattern of behavior
and likewise breaking the law under this
consideration would be unjust
so i decide
screw it i'm not going to pay my taxes
anymore
i become a law breaker by that and
thereby i become
unjust and the longer i do it the more
occasions on which i do it the more
unjust i am
so this is a conception
of justice which
aristotle doesn't spend a lot of time
exploring
in terms of motive in terms
of habits he he
why why not well he's reflecting a sort
of common
understanding of you're you're a
a just person provided you remain within
certain boundaries certain guardrails if
you will
that are laid down by the laws
and they can change over time new laws
can be added
laws can be revoked but at any given
time
you're just if you remain within that
and you're unjust if you're straying
outside of the
boundaries now he says a few other
things that are very important for
making sense out of this
there's a conception of law at work here
that you might call aspirational he says
that
laws should aim at the common good
he doesn't actually say that it
necessarily is the common good of all he
says
the common good of most or
of all or of a certain class or of the
rulers
and what he's what he's picking out
there is the fact that
laws are not always even though they may
be intended
for the common good they often end up
uh helping out one group but not another
and some people do enact laws
um which are primarily to the benefit of
their their class their
their group could be based on on race if
you think about you know segregation
laws in the south
and the question is
is it right to obey those sorts of laws
do those also embody this this kind of
justice it seems like
aristotle would have to say that in at
least in some respects
laws can be more or less just
and then you want you know some sort of
other criteria he's not actually talking
about that
here but he is saying so they should aim
at the common good
they should be promoting the general
happiness
they should be providing for the
advantage of of
the society and how would they do that
this is something distinctively
not necessarily aristotelian but
distinctively
hellenic
they should produce virtue and they
should
prohibit vice so for example
one of the vices would be
excessive anger and does the law
forbid things that people tend to want
to do
given excessive anger yes uh he gives
examples of this
in the nick of mccain ethics and also in
the politics he says for example
the law says when you get angry at
somebody you're not supposed to hit them
and so the law says don't strike people
and if you do here's the penalties for
it
uh it also says you shouldn't slander
them you shouldn't
say certain bad things about them even
though you're angry at them and you
might feel that they're true at the time
and good laws are designed to sort of
you know
steer us away from the things that that
are vicious
and if we you know fail in in steering
ourselves away from that then they
punish us
so that we say i don't want to do that
again and they also should steer us
towards
behavior that is virtuous one of the the
open questions
that you should think about is what
to what degree are laws on their own
capable of actually producing the kinds
of habits in people
that that we call virtue and that's a
very interesting question
one that it goes beyond the scope of
this this core concept video
in any case this is aristotle's
conception of
what law ought to be doing and he
concedes that in many cases it may not
actually be doing that so
the question that you want to ask
yourself then is
is it still good to obey laws that
perhaps were
not designed for the advantage of all
but designed for the advantage of
of some people or were kind of thrown
together in a haphazard manner he
actually does
talk about that he says when the laws
are made hastily
they're made less well um
aristotle would say that in general
again in general
even if the laws aren't the best laws
that they could be and by the way he
doesn't think that in most cases
at least in his contemporary uh greece
they were the best laws they could be
it's still good to follow the laws
in general that that is a type of
justice to follow
the patterns that are that are in place
um it's still a bad thing to break the
law
even if the law is kind of a stupid law
you know so you might say well
think about jaywalking for example it's
illegal in many places to jaywalk
and you might say look it's really
inconvenient for me to have to like go
all the way to the
to the crosswalk there's no cars coming
let me just cross here and aristotle
would say yeah maybe in that
circumstance
um you're not actually you know doing
any sort of injustice you're not doing
an unjust act but in general you you
should walk to the crosswalk
because they made these rules and we
we follow them so that it does tend to
promote some sort of common
common good he stresses that legal
justice
is not the same thing as natural justice
what does he mean by natural justice
natural justice is that which
people acknowledge as being
right or wrong pretty much universally
so you know most societies for example
forbid incest
there are a few that that actually do go
along with it
but aristotle would say look those are
screwed up societies
uh that's why they're exceptions that
you know to the
the general rule um
there are certain things that aristotle
would say are moral norms
that most people can
get and those would be embodied in what
he's calling natural justice
legal justice is what is more
particularized for
a given community with its own history
with its own conflicts with its own
particular preoccupations
working from you know the best
understanding that they have at the time
and embodied in some sorts of codes
that are if not necessarily
you know universally intelligible or
transparent or at least accessible
to people so they can say look here's
what the law actually says
you're either going to do it or you're
not and so you know we come back to
where we started
where following those sorts of codes is
what counts as
just in that case and breaking
those rules is what's counting as
unjust